[Music]
Bulgaria has started a big PR campaign
to boost the vaccination Drive
so far only 20 of the population has
been inoculated
vaccine hesitancy is widespread in this
Balkan Nation
I'm very skeptical about these vaccines
they've been developed too fast
I'm not afraid of the coronavirus and
I'm not going to get vaccinated
Bulgaria already has one of the highest
kobit 19 mortality rates in the EU as
Western Europe emerges from the pandemic
Bulgaria is facing a harsh winter
Welcome to our covid-19 special I'm
Monica Jones good to have you with us
now is it a relic of the Cold War the
fear of a new form of subjugation or
just misinformation fact is bulgarians
have little desire to be vaccinated even
though case numbers are rising
the head doctor of the covet station in
this Bulgarian Hospital refuses to give
covert vaccinations atanus mangarov is a
well-known pediatrician at the hospital
for infectious diseases he gives tetanus
and measles vaccinations but not those
for covert 19.
no I don't vaccinate against covert it's
great for everyone who wants to be
vaccinated do it there is a vaccine but
I don't think it is right to force
people in the fear that otherwise they
can't work and live as normal that is
fascism
vaccine skepticism is widespread in
Bulgaria here a party of pro-russia
nationalists protests coronavirus
regulations which had previously been
much more relaxed than those in
countries like Germany
I refuse to wear a mask I think it's
crazy idiotic and humiliating every
doctor I trust has told me not to do it
because the infection rate is on the
rise the government has implemented new
hygiene rules clubs are closed and large
events can only be held at 50 capacity
vaccination is eminently possible in
Bulgaria in this shopping center it can
be done for free and without appointment
but interest is low
most people don't believe that the
vaccine helps but I think even if it
only helps a little it's better than
nothing
when it comes to the vaccine
statistically we're down at the bottom
in Europe and in the world sadly we in
the Balkans are distrustful and open to
myths and fairy tales and fears and
unverified information
the young doctor here agrees even among
medical staff there are many against the
covert vaccine he says and then there's
the hesitant government
the worst for me Isn't the slow
implementation of regulations to fight
the pandemic but that our health system
is on the brink of collapse and doctors
aren't supporting it
Bulgaria's covert death rate is higher
than that of any other EU State and
clearly so is its vaccine skepticism
epidemiologist and part of the national
covet surveillance team in Bulgaria she
studied vaccine hesitancy in the country
I also say hello to Janina steinage he's
Professor for Global Health at the
Technical University in Munich hello to
both of you I would like to start with
you Savina because covet mortality rate
in Bulgaria is among the highest in the
EU only about 20 percent of the
population there are vaccinated and we
don't even know that number for sure we
don't know how many people have fake uh
certificates why are so many people
there including doctors hesitant to get
vaccinated
yes we have uh thank you we have
actually become a cautionary tale of uh
the tall vaccine hesitancy can take
um vaccine hesitancy here is not a new
problem uh Bulgaria has consistently
ranked high on vaccine hesitancy
measurements uh across the planet in
different studies the reasons are
different it depends on the
subpopulation you study it can be very
diverse but one overarching thing that
we find in our uh various interviews and
studies we've done is uh distrust and
this is deep uh distrust towards
institutions including Public Health
institutions when that distress reaches
a certain threshold you have a situation
where people will look closer to home
for advice of sources that may not be
well equipped to provide good
information so that would be relatives
friends colleagues and will be reluctant
to actually follow guidance coming from
standard expert institutions
right I mean and you know you as I
mentioned uh you were researching about
vaccination hesitance in age European
countries how does the situation compare
so in Bulgaria we definitely have the
highest level of vaccine hesitancy uh 59
in our study of men were vaccine
hesitant towards the covid-19 vaccines
and 66 of women and we see several
reasons for that based on our
qualitative data so there are five key
reasons for this vaccine hesitancy there
are fears of side effects concerns about
the potential harmful long-term
consequences of the vaccine especially
in view of the recent and quite fast
development then there are General
um concerns about the efficacy and
quality of the vaccines partly based on
the finding that vaccinated individuals
can still transmit the virus and some of
our respondents call into question the
threat posed by the pandemic or even
they even deny the existence of the
covid-19 pandemic all together and
therefore they don't see the benefits of
getting vaccinated and then lastly what
was just mentioned by my colleague one
of the key reasons is also distrust
towards political Elites and the
political system altogether and some of
our respondents refer to vaccination as
a sort of means of State control or
state oppression
so what what do we do about it I mean
there's obviously sort of false
information out there uh there is a lot
of doubt about the efficacy conspiracy
theories all of that plays a role Yanina
what would be policy conclusions that
emerge from the findings you just
mentioned
yeah it's very uh interesting this
question and we set out to test
different communication strategies so
that we can generate an evidence-based
on how we can reduce vaccine hesitancy
um but we find in our study that there's
not an outright answer we find a lot of
heterogeneity in terms of how some of
these communication strategies which
work effectively in some countries but
not in others and in Bulgaria none of
the strategies that we tested for
example one of the communication
messages tried to emphasize the risk
reduction achieved by the vaccines one
of the messages tried to emphasize
hedonistic benefits and restoration of
public life associated with vaccination
and one of the messages pointed to the
covid-19 vaccination passport that could
then give individuals certain access
rights but none of these messages proved
successful in reducing the hesitancy
level in Bulgaria so actually the main
in conclusion from our study is that
there's no
one-size-fits-all strategy for Europe as
such and that we need to carefully
tailor messages to individual countries
and better understand the worries and
concerns in each Target population and
in Bulgaria this would involve targeting
specifically women and more
disadvantaged individuals with lower
educational background and lower income
levels
our last question to you brief answer if
you could uh how do you think could this
health literacy in Bulgaria be improved
um it's really a matter of trust here
um communication is key there's no
Central uh one-size-fit-all
um solution but we do have people on the
ground even with cases and doctors we
have a lot of doctors and professionals
on the ground who are actually they know
their communities they talk to their
communities and they are well equipped
to communicate well what we need here is
uh support managerial and and a
political will to support a wide
communication strategy where we involve
those people on the ground that our best
place to help in our situation now
epidemiologist and part of the national
covet surveillance in Bulgaria and
Yanina steinert Professor for Global
Health at the Technical University in
Munich thank you so much for your time
for one of your questions now over to
Derek Williams
what's the best approach in talking to
people who have adopted conspiracy
theories about covet 19.
talking to people who've adopted
conspiracy theories especially if
they're people that you care deeply
about that can be a very difficult and
delicate matter but there are a few
approaches that pretty much all of the
experts in this field agree on the first
thing is that it's important to remain
calm even if you feel like screaming
sometimes because though it might make
you feel better for a minute or two
screaming has never convinced anyone of
anything in other words it's important
to always treat the person that you're
talking to with respect no matter how
much you disagree with their views even
if they believe in things that to you
might seem ridiculous after all you
expect that from them too right
the topic is so charged here in Germany
that the government has even published
advice in the form of some fundamental
recommendations first is something that
a lot of people forget which is to
solidly prepare for any discussion with
someone who's adopted conspiracy
theories
by informing yourself first about the
topic as thoroughly as you can the
second recommendation
is to actually talk to the person
involved don't have the conversation via
text
and have the talk in a private setting
because the goal is not to publicly
shame anyone
third is to have an open calm discussion
where you ask questions about their
opinions without acting as though you
think that those opinions are absurd or
stupid because she prepared for the
conversation in advance by doing your
own research
you should have a list of respectable
sources offered to share those sources
and talk about them at a future date
unfortunately experts in this area also
mostly agree that that once people go
down the rabbit hole it can be very hard
to get them back out again so
don't expect instant success
[Music]
and that's all for now thanks for
watching stay safe
[Music]